she's used to all of these bottles if it
were yep that's Koreans for ya
[Music]
we love soju so I've had soju before but
not flavored soldiers soju is dangerous
it's smooth its watery I take pictures a
lot we can show you yeah if you like
sweet and you like fruity flavors you
might like this more than me actually I
love peach this is how Koreans drink
cuz I'm 27 was 28 we were out drinking
and I was like shower door so turn me on
no we gonna be a little time John it
tastes just like Pete ring I'm so into
it oh that's not even alcoholic it's
probably too sweet for you right now
you can feed this to children wait don't
do that so when you pour soju for people
if they're older than you you have to
use two hands support so your order nine
times this one tastes a lot like fresca
like a soda a things like Freddie I do
like very clearly see how I could drink
a whole bottle of this and not realize
how silly I'm getting
how do you grapefruit a little bit of
salt in a spoon oh you cut it in half
and then spoon it out how do you eat
great food like an orange huh
this smells delightful it's gonna be a
candle hmm mmm that was good that's
incredibly good that is not alcohol
I don't like grapefruits and I don't
know why I thought I like this this
seems like the closest like the actual
flavor the food these tastes like melted
popsicle concentrate flavor that you
would know from like screams what ice
creams are you eating a sorbet oh this
is awful
I love the women on these shuttin down
that smells like cough syrup Oh
blueberries should not be mixed with
soju that's not good it does not taste
like blueberries oh no this tastes like
kids medicine head it's a straw how does
that taste
tastes like Liberty this one sucks that
blueberry flavor
no no this is how it's supposed to be a
bridge
I'm sorry Korea perfect got it it smells
topical feels like I'm in Malaysia right
now come to me that whoa will do sweet
for me oh that's a bad aftertaste that's
the problem
it's like pineapple that was left in a
cup of water overnight this pineapple is
amazing you're just continuing to drink
she's like juice maybe you know what
he's not pineapple it's not made of
pines or apples whoa oh god it smells
even more like fruit punch than the last
this is like when you go to the
dentist's office and they're like what
type of flavor would you like on your
gas mask and I'm like I'll take red
please it's a straight-up melted
starburst how do they distill this it is
a pretty subtle flavor but I like that
I've never been a huge fan of flavored
so Jews because I feel like it's just
drinking juice
I like our liquor to taste like it's
designed for like my little sister and
Steven Lee I'll bet he's having a great
time he's probably being way too loud I
bet he's like oh all right drink up
Koreans need to take over the tastes
making cool thing about people in Korea
really fast internet hot girls I'm
really sorry
get at me